when you're like 15 16 you don't realize
that you're not even born yet they
literally are sitting there thinking
they're getting close to having to have
their [__] figured out kids I got a big
one for you you know how your parents
and teachers are telling you like you
got to get [__] focused you got to
figure out your [__] you're not going to
believe this it's really [__] funny
none of them have their [__] figured out
none none it's a big passion of mine
people that follow me here know how much
I pound this with modern medicine do you
know that they're going to live to 130
real [__] they need to be highrisk they
need to follow their actual dream
actually they need to mitigate regret
you know what is really hurting for a
lot of people in here the [__] they
didn't do at 20 and 30 that they wanted
to cuz they thought they were supposed
to or their mommy made them do it or
Society told us I get it but if you're a
musician if you want to be a
stay-at-home Dad if you want to coach
little leag whatever it is at this age
for the next 20 years nothing but that
and then if you didn't have the talent
if it didn't bounce your way if you
weren't good enough if it just didn't
click then at the rip age of
33 you can go get a regular job